foreign
there's no such thing as an unbeatable
fault
[Music]
that's weatherproof shockproof
and
[Music]
Thief proof
this is the most secure fault in the
United States maybe in the world
[Music]
so what's the score seven billion
dollars give or take
what's the split
even Steven across the board
who ate spaghetti with chopsticks like a
billion people
say there's Biometrics unintroppable
power supply and security teams who are
ready to use deadly force
she basically robs herself
this is who we're up against Roger Salas
the world believes he is a Titan of
industry and a man of virtue the world
is wrong
you could have come in with me Ray by
the memories together I was betrayed no
no and now he has everything and I have
a way to make things even
we are taking money from some of the
most powerful people on Earth we got a
chance to fix everything that ever went
wrong in our lives are you in anyone
[Music]
foreign
let's go
I'm a regular guy that got caught up in
extraordinary circumstances
this story is as accurate as it is
unbelievable
I couldn't make this up it happened to
me
call is this what happened it's all been
put in the book
I'm a single dad raising my son Johnny I
always brought Johnny with me on my
first dates and I came across a woman
family oriented stay-at-home mom Audrey
let's cut there
he's the main guy he's gonna play
himself guilty as charged your honor wow
that's weird action shortly after we
were married she was trying to fleece
Paul out of money what'd you do I'm
getting a psychic reading I'm Terry J
I'm a pet psychic I'm sensing that this
is bigger than we think what I said that
that started the discoveries holy
of her secret double life she had a
secret phone and she had secret
addresses this is the spot this woman
must be stopped
I went and paid a visit to the FBI this
story every time you turn over a rock
I'm the warrior now you'll find several
more Pebbles Goosebumps I'm in full
stealth mode this case haunts me it
started off here and it just went here
[Music]
Scotty I'm in the Twilight Zone
I don't know that it means no no no this
is the spin now don't worry it'll be
great
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Google
[Music]
do you have iceberg
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I finally understand why George is
always running
foreign
act like everything's normal I can't
help feeling like it's all wrong
you missed them I don't I like them gone
it's peaceful quiet less watching in my
every move I know this engagement is
fast not about Paul dad mom always has a
new guy she farts and like eight guys
fall in love with her I am love oven
that's really making me feel good
I was a different person when I moved
here I didn't have a future before a
career real friends
I know things have been tense you
embezzled funds and then threatened me
and I apologize for that no actually you
didn't
Nick I'm very sorry
Jenny your mom was a dangerous person
I know you think she would know you or
your brother
but that doesn't mean she wouldn't hurt
someone else
all right
my whole family's broken it's getting
hard to pretend that something's not
going on with you
I feel like what I'm going through and
who I am is just completely invisible to
you
[Music]
I'm just I'm damaged and I'm scared I'm
gonna screw this up I can't tell if I'm
the crazy one or if everyone else is
oh you're crazy
you always do this you cut and run when
things get hard
I'm not normal I'm a damaged trailer
park team my murderer
[Music]
want me to kill him that's not funny
it's a little bit fun
foreign
[Music]
welcome to the murder capital of the
world
learn how to be a real man by making an
honest living the turf war has escalated
I already told you I'm out just know
you'll get my money on time
I'm gonna kill you the 50 boys dead
Wall Street
take over the nation
I thought you was done get in the game
or stay out of it
if you were my woman I cherish you know
you're talking to one of the biggest
players in Detroit right
I can respect that brother well remember
Pride often comes before the fall
I don't know who to trust in his family
anymore you better stick together no
matter what my sons did not come from a
broken home they came from a broken City
I don't get to pick and choose who we
see
region I are businessmen we are about to
turn be a method to a global Empire
[Music]
thank you
thanks for having my back notice for
life
I've spent years
belting the life I thought I wanted but
there's something inside of me something
that I can't explain and I'm afraid
[Music]
can't control
I don't understand anything that's
happening to me
this power goes way back in your family
to all the mayfairs have gifts
you're just beginning to see the World
Behind the world if you open your mind
you can be transformed
are some who will lie to you evil comes
in many forms
we're bound together
I'm used to command
your gift is the strongest thing I've
ever felt
the darkness is in Earth
you're special Can you feel it for the
first time in my life
exactly
who I am
you make a good team what he means is he
couldn't do it without me
[Music]
safe hands now
surviving Seafood you really must start
taking more responsibility on trying
you're extremely trying you really are
the most ridiculous creature
I hope you're referring to the dog
[Music]
go off to their training whilst I stayed
here to protect more people by
preventing TB spread than you ever would
with a gun
I can't lose him everyone under this
roof is in my care
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
those men back there were bounty hunters
all of his place a price on your head
and my sisters
[Music]
for the cries you run from have not
ceased
we are now on different paths but you
are not giving up
I will sit on a throne of Norway do you
think you're the only one who is
desperate to get there
you must transport something of great
Worth to the emperor Constantinople I
think you could be the man too healthy
thank you if I have any chance of taking
what is rightfully mine we must make
money doing what
what we're gonna Freddy's
[Applause]
welcome to John's book
you have two choices
or do what Vikings have always done they
invent themselves take what is
rightfully off
let's go
I cannot guarantee anyone's survival I
can only guarantee my best efforts to
Keep Us Alive
brace yourselves
I'm a warrior
he came to us for a greater purpose than
as a warrior I think you're here to find
a better life
[Music]
fortune favors the boat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me live and I will bring you the
biggest prize you could imagine head of
Hitler
one more run and everything that we have
done would have been worth it
we can't do it alone so where are you
friends we're all here
even though it doesn't retire so why
should we where's the extra gun for me
maybe a bunch of Eagle Scouts
they will do everything in their power
to find us
but huge
well
when now we can finally begin
you don't recognize me but it's been a
long time
it's time I told you the truth about
Leanne Grace
when she first came to this house
it was an act of love
that love was a selfish love
it has brought death and destruction
down upon us all
people keep getting hurt in this house
again
when she's happy things are good
it's just angry things go bad
I'm not who I used to be
she scares me
I just like more
I hurt people when I get angry
scariest part is that I'm starting to
like the way that it feels scar
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I just can't get enough
foreign
nothing stays hidden in the town
the consequence of a riot is our new
reality we need a pecking order inside
gentlemen so we have control on the
outside and that reality is chaos
you know the deal like 10 49. you can't
get the product in can't get no money
out it's them guards they're choking us
to death
I have an idea it's gonna sting but it
will work
I'm gonna trust you on this
you need help Mike let's work together
we need time to heal I'm talking about
I'm fine
we're gonna make things right but
brother gotta be patient okay okay
love you
virus they're going to give you a new
identity I don't want to go I'm not safe
anymore
Milo is enlisted on the inmate roster
you know what that means
would you just walk out the front gate
maybe this is the disaster Evelyn
my cool even Saints have their Breaking
Point
it's getting out of hand Mike you can't
even control your own people
we want to start we're out here you want
us to stop me police Mikey but it's
gonna be some payback I need you to
continue trusting me the inmates are
running the assignment
open up the goddamn key this was what
I'm trying to stop
give us in there and do a thing
I think it's done
they say a lion doesn't know that he's
cage until he's let out I got a taste of
Freedom now I just can't go back into
the cage
that heroine was the one chance I had to
control these blocks
now we're Crawling Back to the Italians
with my checkbook
it's just not equipped to carry that
kind of debt I need some time money's
due to Joe Colombo
Bumpy Johnson you can make up your death
to the families by working with me and
if I say no
why would you do that
you're either gonna work with the
Italians or you're going to fight them
one will kill to protect what he has
your statements help throw the five
families into disarray the other to
demand what he hasn't
but we're going to win our fight for
freedom I need alliances with the
African leaders I'll help you I'll do
whatever it takes
[Music]
I'm done shaking hands with Italians
they want to keep me in shackles I call
the shots me and me alone
[Music]
we're on the edge of War money how much
Manpower we got we wouldn't have a
chance against all five families you
look great we're losing our grip on
Central harlems
you and I believe we can solve all our
problems by ourselves we can't you need
an alliance set a meat with Jose battle
you can help us change the balance of
power
I'll deal with monkey Johnson they need
to get as far away as possible
this is our last shot you either with me
Hustle are you dead
Powder Keg situation
this is a suicide mission hey will
someday get me killed there's one thing
you guys never seem to remember why
Harlem
it's mine
yeah
[Music]
if you don't think there's hope for the
world
while they're going on
I've seen the world
so you don't know
keep going for family
I'm not family no
cargo
[Music]
why are you so important
Somewhere Out West they're working on a
cure I think what really impressed them
was the fact that I didn't turn into a
monster you see so much as twitches
it's okay
[Music]
if I'm taking you with me
do what I say when I say
get any advice on the best way west
yeah go
go you've come this far
and you know what's out there
you're not going to scare us
scared him
[Music]
never said any of us could have ever
imagined
be careful who you put your faith in
my
father
it's your summons
[Music]
trust me
in the beginning there was the boom
you're a tough little cockroach
no I did not see that coming
honey I'm home
how I'm gonna pay all these bills 300 to
fix our broken urine purifier yeah the
urine purifier is broken my name is Sid
I'm your new employee when you look at
me what do you say oh um an old little
man in the top hat I was gonna say
success success yes we moved to Boomtown
to share a life together like some sort
of ironic performance art no actual life
oh girl I don't care if we live in
Boomtown or the Wasteland as long as I'm
with the same violence spoil that I fell
in love with
I never
be like
this
I am I am you know what I'm just gonna
stop asking questions at this point and
sort of go with it
[Music]
I have to make a shopping list the kids
are gonna want snacks don't feed them
Kitty that's how it started the first
time I'm going to get Fritos Tostitos
Doritos all the guidos I am back baby
son of a [ __ ]
hey Grandma hey Grandpa Leia
tell me about Chicago what are you into
I'm a pretty big deal in the bay club
that's not up for debate
yeah I'm not popular
thank you girl Leia you should buy the
tag
this isn't gonna work I'm pretty sure
Oshkosh because here is gonna get carded
oh look Nick shooting star make a wish
that's a firework babe I wish I could
stay for the summer and stay okay kids
the basement is all yours your grandma
just hooked us up what is it Leia do you
want to hear about the Donkey Kong
conspiracy
interesting it's kind of like how Sheryl
Crow isn't actually a crow
totally if you're worried about fitting
in with everyone else you found the
people who don't fit in
I still can't believe Jaden kissed you
oh my God
my guy's got a bunch of salons you may
have seen his commercials
welcome back to Chances
it's always an honor to have your hair
in my chair
why did you open our house to chaos
again all the dumbasses were gone
cheers
[Applause]
love having the house full again it just
it fills me with joy Eric's having a
hard time with Leia but all I know is
that I'm going to love her and stand
behind her no matter what that is a
great idea
because when you stand behind your kids
it's easy thanks
[Music]
oh
Gods above us
dragons attacking together
it's like the end of the world and what
exactly is the plan against four dragons
[ __ ]
oh
this is gonna be fun
I am very flammable
how about we get a drink
I hope you fall into lava attacks
oh that's a new record usually takes us
10 minutes to get kicked out of a palace
these weapons were created to strike
down the gods find them to defeat the
dragons
foreign
the other way oh God
foreign
premieres January 20th on the on Prime
video the balls are ice cubes don't you
worry Uncle girl
this is actually kind of cozy about
about to go
travel from pole to pole
more than a decade ago the first series
of Frozen planets examined life in the
Arctic and the Antarctic
now we will explore all of Earth's
Frozen habitats from its highest peaks
to its snowbound deserts
too deep beneath
foreign
[Music]
Wildlife found in our Frozen
wildernesses
[Music]
this is frozen planet 2.
foreign